I'm of two minds about this on the one
hand they do have some really appealing
properties where you can explain certain
types of correlations that we observe
like as a matter of fact we can explain
them very easily but on the theoretical
side they don't seem to work
[Music]
properly thank you very much we all know
the story of Newton framing his theory
of gravity as a result of watching an
apple fall from a tree but 350 years on
we still don't understand this seemingly
simple Force so current theories cannot
apply both at the small scale of atomic
particles and at the giant scale of
galaxies or on the scale of quantum
mechanics and on the scale of general
relativity without a solution the
mystery of gravity threatens to
undermine any overall account of the
universe now is the fault for this with
Einstein's theory of general relativity
or with our understanding of quantum
mechanics do we need an entirely
different account of gravity or perhaps
remove Gravity from our explanations
altogether or should we just accept that
a single holistic account of the
universe is not possible and see our
theories as limited to a given frame and
reference so I'm delighted to be on
stage here as the philosopher of science
with three of the world's top physicist
we have a fantastic panel for you Saina
hosen felter is a physicist who
specializes in the foundations of
physics uh she is the host of the
YouTube channel sence without the Goble
deg which I believe just reached one
million
subscribers uh priia
Nat uh is a professor of astronomy and
physics at Yale University whose
research is on the Dark Universe She is
the author of The pioneering work
mapping the heavens the radical
scientific
Cosmos Eric verinda to my left is a
theoretical physicist and string
theorist he is famous for the verinda
formula and winner of the Spinosa prize
Eric is developing his own radical
theory of
gravitation so welcome to the panelist
and to all of you for being present so
we begin by the simple question can we
solve the mysteries of gravity and if so
how so for this I invite uh Sabina to
begin thank you and thanks everyone for
being here uh it's always good to be in
London so since I'm the first to get to
say something I want to say a little
more about the problem that we're
talking about in the first place so we
have we know of four different
fundamental forces in physics that's the
electromagnetic force that most of you
have probably heard of then we have the
strong and weak nuclear force and we
have gravity and the problem is that
three of those forces the
electromagnetic IC and the two nuclear
forces have Quantum properties so we
have some particles like electrons and
quar and clu and stuff like this and we
know that they do funny things like they
obey the uncertainty principle they can
be in two places at the same time that
kind of weird stuff and then there's
gravity which is described by Einstein's
theory of general relativity and that
theory doesn't know anything about
Quantum properties
and this brings up the question if I
have a particle like an electron that
can be in two places at the same time
and it has a mass and that mass
generates a gravitational Pole where
does the gravitational pole go you'd
expect that to also go to two places at
the same time but Einstein's theory
can't make that work because it doesn't
know anything about Quantum properties
so this leaves us in this weird position
where we just don't know what the
gravitational pull of an electron is so
it's a it's a really simple question
like what's going on with the
gravitational field of this electron and
we don't know and um if you ask like
more technically uh what's the matter
it's just that those two theories the
quantum field theories that we used to
describe particles uh like the electron
and a couple of other
particles um Einstein's the of general
relativity they're just mathematic
particularly incompatible if we just put
them together it doesn't work but nature
knows how it works so there's got to be
a solution to this uh and we don't know
what it is there have been many people
have tried to solve this problem what we
need is a theory of quantum gravity so a
theory that gives properties to gravity
at least that's the way that it's
normally put but more generally we need
some way to resolve this discrepancy
between between the two theories and the
probably best known approach to this is
string theory that most of you would
have heard of there are other ideas like
uh luk quantum gravity and then there
are less wellknown ones like maybe as
ASM totically save uh gravity and stuff
like this but so far we don't know if
any of those is correct uh or how we can
even test them and yes I think it's a
really big problem now when it comes to
my personal opinion on what to do as I
just said like people have worked on
this problem for a long time it's been
known since the 1930s or something so
it's definitely not a new thing and
there are lots of smart people have
spent their whole life trying to fix
something that they think is wrong with
gravity and I have a lot of respect for
all those people and if they couldn't
make it work I'm pretty sure I can't
make it work either so this is why I
think it's a better strategy to try try
and figure out if not there's something
wrong with the quantum side of things
that the problems may be caused by us
not understanding what quantization
means in the first place excellent uh
Eric yes uh can we understand the
mysteries of gravity I do think that
Newton and already Einstein know a lot I
mean they describe a lot about gravity
that well they solved partly the mystery
of gravity but we are now a century
further and we need have to think about
how to combine this theory that Einstein
wrote down general relativity with what
we know about the microscopic world the
quantum mechanics and indeed we are
learning that uh we may have to rethink
uh gravity again and try to understand
uh where it comes from but basically
what are the foundations of what what
gravity is and the way we have been
approaching this and and just not just
me but but many scientists in the world
is by thinking about places in our
universe where anded things make down
from from relativity so these are places
like near black holes black holes turned
out to have what are called Horizons uh
Beyond which light cannot escape and and
step Hawking I think everyone knows him
of course is famous for discovering that
when you combine General activity with
quantum mechanics that there are special
things happening near Horizons and when
we take his results and his his
scientific breakthroughs basically
seriously they tell us that we should
indeed rethink gravity maybe think about
how to understand it from a more
microscopic uh perspective So my answer
to the question is should we change
general relativity or quantum mechanics
I would say that that uh the way I
approach this and actually many of my
colleagues is that we take quantum
mechanics as a working Theory and then
try to understand how the microscopic
descript destion of space and time which
sort of directly related to what what
gravity is U how how that leads to the
gravitational force so we like to
understand the origin of gravity at a
more deeper level so I would say the
problem of quantum gravity is not how do
we apply quantum mechanics to gravity
but how do we understand where gravity
comes from from a quantum theory that's
that's underlying it so I will I will be
saying more about this uh later but my
answer indeed is well we can understand
better what gravity is I think we have
already very good description but we can
make a Next Step by thinking more about
uh well the connection with quantum
mechanics okay excellent so priia can we
solve the mysteries of gravity and if so
how yeah I think that we can solve the
mysteries of um uh gravity and I think
that um I agree with both Saina and Eric
that um you know what we are aspiring to
is sort of a synthetic description of
gravity that combines a microscopic view
with the macroscopic view Einstein's
theory of general relativity has been
incredibly successful so far in the
settings that we've been able to test it
right so in my opinion the new Theory
and we know Einstein's theory is
incomplete we know that already the
question is how do we complete it and
what will show us the way and data will
show us the way right I think um more
accurate data sets Precision
measurements in the cosmos that actually
tests the limits of uh Einstein's theory
are the way forward I think because I
believe if you look at the history of
science look at the history of ideas in
um in um theories of gravity it's really
data that leads way that opens up that
you see a gap in a current description
and there are multiple data sets
multiple independent lines of evidence
that show you that there is a gap this
uh there is there are data that are not
explained within the current framework
and that kind of leads you and shows you
the way and you know if you look at
Newton's Theory versus gr for example
although Einstein didn't set out to
solve the problem you know when the uh
orbit of Uranus could not really be
explained fully with you know Newtonian
description um there was a lot of panic
right and they thought oh my God this
sacred Theory do we have to give it up
already it turns out that the solution
was within Newtonian gravity itself
right that there was a perturber there
was Neptune the location of Neptune was
predicted and it was found so um
similarly U and so the theory just had
to be modified you didn't have to
overthrow the theory meanwhile when
mercuries the peran procession of
mercury could not be explained uh there
was no adjustment you know you couldn't
there were suggestions that maybe there
was another planet maybe there was
Vulcan that was in between the Sun and
Mercury but that's not a that was not a
that didn't work as a solution right so
something else was needed you couldn't
tweak Newtonian gravity to explain that
and you needed Einstein theory of uh
general relativity to actually describe
uh and account for the observations so
we were able to do this because we were
able to get more precise uh observations
more accurate data over longer times so
I really believe that data will lead the
way and that we already know that
Einstein's theory is incomplete and we
do expect a Reconciliation between the
microscopic and the
microscopic okay so we have uh three
Divergent positions on the same problem
uh let's try to dig into a little bit
more of the core of the debate so we
move on now to the First theme which has
already been outlined from the start
does default lie in our theory of with
the theory of gravity lie with
Einstein's theory of relativity or with
the current interpretations of quantum
mechanics and I'd like to invite Sabina
to elaborate on this question and your
own view first okay so um I don't think
the issue is with the interpretation of
quantum mechanics I actually think we do
need a better Theory than quantum
mechanics and the reason I think this is
that um I mean maybe let me say I I
agree with Priya that uh data has to
lead the way because this is science
right so uh we need to observe something
and then try to explain it and I think
the same is true for quantum gravity
eventually we'll need some kind of some
kind of observation that we'll have to
explain but the question is where do we
look and for this you need some kind of
theoretical approach that says that's
what we need to look for this is what we
need to test so um just because data
eventually will be the decisive Factor
doesn't mean we can just get rid of
theorists right okay um so and and the
we definitely don't want to be out of
business theorists right I mean our jobs
will be in Chardy if we had throw Theory
out right right so we need both
basically um Theory and observation um
now the issue with quantum theory is
that uh this quantization of gravity
isn't the only problem we also have
What's called the measurement problem of
quantum mechanics which is pretty much
as old as uh quantum mechanics itself so
it's even older than the problem of
quantum gravity and the issue with uh
the measurement is that we just don't
know how it works so if we use quantum
mechanics we make a measurement we just
say and now a measurement happens that's
like and our Miracle happens and
everything changes and here's our
measurement result and so we we know how
to apply this theory in the laboratory
because we know a measurement when we
see one but we can't explain what it is
and I think that this problem is going
to become more and more important now
that we're building quantum computers
and all kinds of you know Quantum
measurement devices Quantum sensing and
and and all that kind of thing so this
is where I think the data is going to
come from they'll stumble over it sooner
or later whether they want to or not
not your own work on quantum gravity
would you give the audience a very brief
explanation on how to understand or
conceptualize quantum gravity in this
context for the debate yeah well okay
so you know um when when you when we
talked about the introduction that you
would give I had him strike out the word
theoretical in front of uh physicist
because I don't really understand myself
as a theoretical physicist I work on
phenomenal ology and this is what I've
worked on when it comes to quantum
gravity I've worked on the phenomenology
the reason I don't call myself a
phenomenologist is that no one knows
what it
means so so what it means is that we're
trying to make a connection between
theoretical approaches and how you can
make an an
experiment and that in quantum gravity
I've tried to figure out what we can do
to test it so physicists like to tell a
long story about how we can't test
quantum gravity ever and if that was
true I would have said well then it's
not signs why even think about it but I
don't think it's true and the major
reason I don't think it's true is
that we don't necessarily
need strong gravity to test quantum
gravity which is what a lot of people
seem to think like we need a black hole
or we need to look at the origin of the
universe or something like this what we
actually need is we need some kind of
quantum object that's massive enough so
that we can measure the gravitational
field because think about what I told
you in the beginning we don't know what
the gravitational field is of an
electron why not take something more
massive where because normally more
massive things they don't have Quantum
properties so we can't measure this
effect but this is another thing where
there's a lot of progress in the
technological development they're
bringing more and more massive objects
into Quantum States and at some point
we'll just be able to measure it priia
do you agree that it's a quantum
mechanics that needs to catch up with
theory of gravity that's more
established well I mean I'm actually
agnostic about who needs to catch up
with home I think the question is
they're not reconcilable at the moment
they're not inte you know you can't
integrate them at the moment you know I
I prefer a slightly safer approach
which is why don't we see how far we can
push the general theory of relativity
and see where it breaks because I really
believe that the gaps and where the
theory breaks really points out as
Sabina said right the the quantum
gravity the quantum nature of
macroscopic objects lots of thorny
problems there so this is in many ways a
slightly easier route I would take which
is and I really believe that um very
soon we'll be able to push much further
than we already have uh in terms of
tests of general relativity especially
in the strong region so when you're
testing general relativity the event
Horizons uh telescope for example you
know this is the telescope that produced
The Donut shaped image of this uh black
hole in the center of a nearby Galaxy so
that allowed us to test the predictions
of uh general relativity at a few
percent level and we can push down and I
firmly believe that because I think that
the theory is incomplete it is going to
break and I think we are similarly at U
you know technologically in terms of
instrumentation computation modeling and
understanding we're at a place where we
can get more accurate measurements and
we can test the theory to Greater
precision and I believe that it will
break and that that break will show us
what the next step really should be so
my Approach would be sort of Contra to
Sabinas to say that maybe we already
know gr is incomplete so let's kind of
push it with the data because we know we
can articulate the experiments it's sort
of the as I said it's it's a more sort
of cautious way out um and perhaps an
easy way out because we know how to set
up these experiments we know the limits
of our experiments and therefore if we
can push harder and make more precise
observations and test the theory to to
the sub perent level maybe that's where
we'll see where we need to go next okay
so Eric what do you make of these
approaches that are data will lead the
way and and so on they they are
important uh but I I think that well
from my perspective I come from the
theory side I do call myself a
theoretical physicist and I like to also
like take Theory as a leading uh guide
to which of the two should be changed
and there I mentioned the the important
work of Steven Hawking and his
collaborators uh which is actually about
a point where generativity may break
down namely near the horizons of black
holes and even in in our universe we
have a a horizon where things may break
down and there you notice that that the
loss of gravity actually becomes to look
like what we call are the laws of
thermodynamics those are laws that apply
to gases and and molecules that are
forming a gas and they only describe
everything in terms of temperature in
the case of Hawking this is the Hawking
temperature but also Notions like
entropy and maybe pressure but those are
are things that we understand from a
microscopic level because of the
molecules that make up the gas they are
basically statistical properties of all
the mo motions of the molecules now
turns out that the gravitational
equations look exactly like that and
this is also what we're trying to look
for is name a an explanation of what the
LW of gravity look like as Newton and
Einstein wrote down but then explained
from the microscopic set of molecule say
of space and time and we we are making
progress there because we have been able
to think about black holes really as
quantum mechanical objects where we can
basically derive uh the gravitational
loss just like we can derive these these
uh law of
thermodynamics and so from the theory
side it's it's I would say almost
obvious that that the thing that has to
change is the the the description of
gravity in terms of general relativity
and that we have to get a deeper
understanding of that but eventually of
course we have to take the theory and
see what it implies also for
observations and this is where I think
it's exciting that there are these new
observations of well the Event Horizon
telescope but also gravitational waves
what happens near black holes but also
in the cosmos when we look further out
and more into the past there are
questions we don't fully understand like
what is well things like dark energy or
things that make the universe expand
faster there are all kinds of questions
Associated to that that uh well we we
have to then answer using a new
perspective on this quantum gravity
Theory and so the way I think about
quantum gravity is that we combine
quantum mechanics we start from quantum
mechanics and we leave it as it is and
then explain what what the laws of
gravity are and how we can then derive
general relativity from this more
microscopic Theory okay so Eric
represents a different approach and
let's now move uh a little bit further
into the next theme which will'll
elaborate a bit more on this so the the
question here really is whether we need
an entirely different account of gravity
or perhaps do we need to remove Gravity
from our explanations altogether which
something Eric has previously suggested
uh Pria what is your take on this
question well I mean I think we um it's
hard to it's hard for me to see how we
could remove gravity entirely from our
frame of descriptions of the physical
Universe especially given that um we
really do understand that over the
largest Cosmic scales gravity is what
appears to be ordering the universe
right so I think throwing out gravity
completely completely I think it's not
an option I think the option is to find
uh perhaps you know a more refined
description of what gravity is um and um
I concur with Eric that the the theory
will direct us to what the best
experimental setups are whether um but I
I but I think that you know again you
know we need to push general relativity
we need to think up of new Realms we
know that the strong gravity regime is
where we are likely to see departures
from general relativity and I think we
need more innovative ideas of other
regimes where you could actually test so
I I believe that an alternate new
description is in order because I think
when we look at the current General
relativistic description of the universe
and its constituents there are many open
questions questions and there is a
standard theory that seems to work
reasonably well across a wide range of
scales and I'm referring to all these
dark entities right dark matter um you
know Dark Energy uh and sort of the
entire Cosmic inventory but there are
cracks that are starting to appear from
data very interesting and important
cracks that are starting to appear that
sort of show that maybe this Frame that
maybe we are missing something in this
Frame and as I said it's too early to
tell whether some tweak in the current
theory can accommodate these cracks that
we're seeing or we need something really
brand new I mean I like to believe that
um we of course need to be always open
to something brand new but I think the
number of cracks that are starting so
there are many of these what are called
crises in cosmology that are starting to
show up so there's a you know problem
with the measurements of the Cobble
constant in the near Universe far
universe so sort of reconciling distant
scales is becoming an issue and I think
it points to the fact that we can't
dispense with gravity but we probably
need a new kind of explanation indeed
and there are uh many cracks that are
appearing nowadays and that is reframing
a bit of the debate in cosmology uh
which makes it pertinent this kind of
question about where gravity fits into
the into the picture uh Sabina do you uh
agree that there is that you what do you
make of this idea that we could come up
with the description that would remove
gravity altogether or um would you think
there's an entirely different account of
gravity that's
possible well I would first like to try
to
clarify uh the trend that this
discussion has taken because we started
out talking about quantum gravity and
now you say well we should push the
boundaries of general relativity looking
astrophysics black holes uh and so on
and so forth and it's true of course
that we do have problems with general
relativity looking out in the cosmos
because we don't really understand
what's going on with with galaxies why
do they rotate so fast what's going on
with Galaxy clusters uh why does the
universe why does the expansion of the
universe accelerate this is why we've
introduced those things called Dark
Matter and dark energy but those are
different problems than the ones that we
started out with like the ones with the
quantization of gravity and they might
be related or they might not be related
so um I see the problem that you might
you know you might test the boundaries
of general relativity looking at uh
black Hool uh whatever but the solution
to those problems might not require
actually fixing the problem of the
quantization of gravity it might just be
that we have to modify gravity um or
this is a more complicated dark meta
model uh that kind of thing now when it
comes to throwing out gravity I think
that question is somewhat of a red
herring because we we know that gen
relativity is a great Theory certainly
we're not going to throw it out that
would be Madness but what might happen
is that we might find an underlying
Theory from which it can be
derived for example String Theory uh is
one of those candidates but it might be
something else and then we would say
well gravity is emergent from something
else um and it must it doesn't have to
be String Theory could be some other
atoms of SpaceTime or things like
that Eric is uh yeah gravity or red
herring no I understand so gravity is
something that we experience so we need
to have an explanation MH well we first
can accept that's there and then we can
describe it but an explanation might
also be that you start from a theory
where you don't assume Gravity from the
beginning and then you start looking at
what happens when when we start
describing physical objects and what
space in time R and then we discover
that gravity is a natural consequence of
that theory and sort of just like what I
mentioned for for the laws of
thermodynamics of gases and so on if I
look at an individual molecule uh
temperature doesn't mean anything it's
the molecules together that give us the
impression of a temperature because they
they together move and then while having
a large number of molecules these laws
become make sense so this is what we
also call imers the ter term was already
mentioned namely that you start from a
microscopic Theory and then describe
what happens when you combine well go to
larger distances for instance and then
gravity can appear so I think that
microscopically the world doesn't care
about gravity but of course we need to
explain what it is so it's not like we
can ignore that there is gravity it is
there and we need to have a theory for
it and general relativity works very
well so you might say well we have to
understand where General relativity
comes from but I also believe that that
there may be circumstances that the
theory that we may derive from the
microscopic perspective may be different
from
General and those circumstances can be
also in galaxies or or in the cosmos and
then well you mentioned Mercury as a
problem and that new Neptune was sort of
in other cases solution maybe dark
matter is a similar uh discrepancy that
we try to sort of solve by adding things
and I think that indeed uh we have to
take those measurements and this
observations seriously as also maybe
indic Cas that there may be something
wrong with the theory of gravity and not
just that there may be some particles
that we haven't found absolutely that is
really what I was alluding to that the
more uh accurate High Precision
measurements may actually show you that
a gap in the theory in the theoretical
description not just a fix like Neptune
where you add in another degree of
freedom and you're able to explain
within the current framework itself yes
so from a philosophical and theoretical
point of view you could say this this
would make seem to make sense as an
approach to widen the frame so as to
make the problem appear in A different
light but uh Sabina from a physics point
of view um do you find this approach uh
useful to pursue or are the problems
with this way of reframing the problem
to get eliminate gravity
well she was just talking about
modifying gravity not eliminating
gravity yeah I think we shouldn't left
anything untried basically and
personally I think there's been too much
time and effort spent on trying to come
up with all kinds of different dark meta
particles you know there are gazillions
of those models and they all make more
or less the same predictions and then
you can adjust them to slightly fit this
type of galaxy a little bit better or
that kind and it didn't really go
anywhere because the model is just too
it's too flexible and there
are very obvious correlations in in the
data as you certainly know like for
example the bionic Tully Fisher relation
that kind of stuff which dark mattera
just can't explain and there are other
modifications of gravity that explain
those things but then they have
different problems so it becomes really
complicated and I generally think it's
not good to um put all bets on one thing
so um I I'm really supportive of
spending some time on modified gravity
and that different approaches to that
kind of thing spending some time on the
idea of trying to replace gravity or
explain it as something emergent or
induced gravity this a similar but
related idea or maybe just saying maybe
the for is with uh the quantum side of
things which is what what I uh
personally work on okay so there we have
three different approaches to this that
you're outlining is the modified gravity
as one way to go there's this emergent
picture of trying to reframe the idea of
gravity to begin with and then you have
quantum gravity so to the three Deb uh
Debaters here if you had to place your
bets priia on either of these you say
you're agnostic but if you had to put
some if I gave you some chips now you
had to put them down on the so what are
the what's the third option so I think
modifying gravity just with a view to
adding um additional degrees of freedom
but stay within the same framework where
other cracks are opening up is clearly
not that's not where I would put my bet
but not little tweaks to the theory but
push it so that the cracks to try to
make sense of all these crises so the
modifying gravity so far has been really
focused on the Dark Matter problem so
new and I think it's the been point out
new zoos of particles right alternative
particles I think that is and that's an
approach that has been tried a lot of
energy has been spent and I think it's
it's it's been useful it's taught us
more but that's not where I would put my
bet on the kind of uh pushing the theory
that I'm talking about is actually
trying to see these crises you know
going Beyond just having a different
kind of dark matter particle I think
that's where things are pushing us
fundamentally look at the nature of dark
energy and what we think dark energy is
for example and then fundamentally
looking at whether these conceptual
ideas of dark matter and dark energy can
somehow be mean could they be two
manifestations of the same thing I mean
you know I think those kinds of ideas
are totally worth exploring and I think
they should be and not as much attention
is being paid to them we've been uh
spending too much uh so I would not bet
on the modifying gravity and I said with
the quantum um with the quantum theory
of gravity I think that there's just
like vast bits of things that we don't
understand so as a pragmatist I would
stick to sort of my view of uh really
pushing the theory of general relativity
with the view of finding a replacement
theory for it and I firmly believe that
we will see new
directions but Sabina this approach to
modifi gravity which has been uh which
has come to the four a lot in the last 5
to 10 years it's really um gained a lot
of uh interest and a lot of research uh
in the field I know you have also
engaged a lot with that field do you see
it as priia suggesting here more that
it's limited kind of tinkering with the
existing model or do you think that
there's a real promise and a kind of a
breakthrough with understanding modified
gravity well as you say I've actually
worked on modified gravity for a couple
of years and uh I used to think it's
really promising it's going to solve all
the all these problems and I don't work
on it anymore because it turned out it
doesn't work quite as well as I thought
it would it's like from a theoretical
side it's really really difficult to
make those theories work and you know
I'm of two minds about this on the one
hand they do have some really appealing
properties where you can explain certain
types of correlations that we observe
like as a matter of fact we can explain
them very easily but on the theoretical
side they don't seem to work properly so
and this I I think I I'm afraid I
actually agree with you it just makes me
feel like we're missing something really
big like there's something fundamentally
wrong with this type of theory because
they don't work with the the mathematics
doesn't work the way that we expect it
to work especially light deflection I
think one of the big you know I was
open-minded like um so mean I dabbled a
little less uh because you know I'm
invested in light detection uh
gravitational lensing those theories are
unable to provide a description and we
see these lenses we see these arcs
Hubble Space Telescope has shown us
these arcs right so well there are there
are models which can explain that kind
of thing but then they have other
problems so it's like you're pushing
around the bump under the carpet you
know it always comes up somewhere so
Eric where would you place your chips
well someone said I mean don't modify
gravity but try to understand it and I
think that's my Approach is I want to
understand gravity and then find answers
and maybe I should mention it here more
more clearly there has been a lot of
progress made in our field in
understanding gravity that comes from
strength Theory we have a theory that
explains Gravity
microscopically the only drawback is
that it's not yet in a universe that
looks like our own it's namely one where
there's no dark energy that makes things
a lot simpler so the step that we need
to make as the is eventually is to
develop this theory that we understand
very well but in a context where there
is dark energy and there I feel that we
can indeed understand gravity to the
level where we can do computations and
make
descriptions that clarify these these
observation not by modifying it but by
really understanding what gravity is to
make clear so I think it's it's starting
from quantum mechanics and then deriving
gravity again and maybe I should mention
that I mean
Newton had a theory of gravity Einstein
didn't modify exactly the equation of
Newton he had a much better much deeper
understanding so the the because he he
combined it with space and time and
everything a curvature of space and time
a totally New Perspective and I think
our next theory of gravity will again
not be a modification of the the laws of
Newton or or the Einstein equations no
it will be a total totally New
Perspective that will be given on what
gravity is what do you see as the
problem with this approach uh Saina do
you see a problem with it or um what
Eric is
outlining no um for me the question
comes down to like strategically what's
the kind of experiment that we should
look at to test those kinds of ideas and
as I was trying to say earlier I think
if you look at astrophysics cosmology
all those kind of big scale questions it
becomes basically impossible to tear
apart the problems with dark meta Dark
Energy uh modified gravity quantum
gravity and then let's not forget there
might be other problems like with uh the
kind of model that we use in general
relativity they might just be too simple
or there might be issues with the
numerical simulations you know they you
know just on the numerical side or
because we're neglecting some kind of
feedback or subgrid parameters and all
kinds of things so this is why I'm
thinking it would be strategically much
better if we looked at something clean
like this kind of tabletop experiment
where we're trying to put those masses
into some kind of uh super positions and
I understand that Priya disagrees
because she things I think that's much
more complex actually coming up with
those experiments because quantum
mechanics is so
complicated um well these are uh I mean
very different kinds of approaches let's
uh let's uh move to the
last theme and try to put this in a
bigger frame again um a little bit uh
also really more
philosophically should we just
accept that a single holistic account of
the universe is not possible should we
see our theories as inevitably just
limited to a given time in a given
reference and accept them as working
within that range only Eric would you
like to begin now I do think that we can
make it next step in understanding
gravity whether it's the final
understanding I don't think that as
humans we can understand everything
about the universe that's one thing the
other thing that I find quite important
is that we also have to realize that we
are here at Planet Earth looking at the
universe out there and that we are doing
observations and we have to explain
those things in a framework that we
invent like space and time and so on but
we are doing it from a certain
perspective so I do think that we should
be aware of the fact that we may have an
incomplete description of everything and
suddenly the edges of the universe may
be sort of Beyond where we can observe
so I think that in our current theories
we have um not enough taken into account
that we are making our observations from
a certain perspective and maybe our
description of what we call the universe
should also be more well from our own uh
reference frame and because you used
that word in your question and I mean I
do think that we have to take into
account that there's a certain Observer
dependence of how we interpret what we
are uh looking mhm but Priya is it
possible to have a single holistic
account or are we just limited the way
we are I I I think we could aspire to it
yeah um and I think I concur with Eric
on this point that from a sense of sort
of cosmic humility right there's no
reason why the brain size of a
gelatinous thing the size of a c vope
should be able to comprehend everything
in the universe including itself so I
believe that there are limits but I
think it is worth uh aspiring to and we
may yet get to a fundamentally different
description that feels more complete
than what we have right now which we
know is incomplete Sabina would you
agree well I certainly agree that we
should aspire to you know Finding an
overarching holistic account of
everything uh but I'm not sure we need
one so when when it comes to this
particular question like can we just
make do with what we have like with um
gr and and quantum theory I think the
answer is clearly no because as I said
in the beginning they're just questions
that we can't answer and sooner or later
we we're going to have a situation in a
laboratory where the theorists can just
say well we don't know we don't have the
theory so we need this Theory so we need
a theory of quantum gravity now do we do
we need a unified theory of everything
that kind of stuff which string theory
is aspiring to I'm not sure about this
you know I guess it would be nice but
it's not really
necessary so if I had an apple in my
hand or you imagine this is an apple I
would do like this this is how we
started we all know uh gravity is an
experiential Force like we all feel it
but we don't know entirely what it is
now we have three of the brightest Minds
working on on this problem on uh here on
stage and I'd like to just ask you a
simple question when you are it could be
a question from either of you anyone
asking you priia what is
gravity oh gosh
uh H uh I think it's very hard for me as
you probably all guessed I'm trapped
within einsteinian theory of general
relativity so
um um I would probably uh defer to that
kind of you know it's a
profound Confluence of space and time
that illuminates the nature of a very
fundamental force that
orders the visible and invisible
Universe Confluence of space and time
that orders our universe and as I said
I'm pretty trapped by Einstein still
right so I think um I haven't broken out
of the box although I'm open to and I
want to break out of the box okay Eric
what is
gravity well just to introduce this I
mean the the way we try to understand
gravity now is by thinking about more
microscopically what space and time is
made of and then we use words like
information especially also the the
quantum information you have to think
about things like what you have on your
computer like data and so on but
SpaceTime is also filled with that
information and gravity I have has
actually written down somewhere uh is
then a consequence of moving information
around so it's the cost mhm of moving
information okay so and that would be a
microscopic explanation of where it
comes from so gravity is consequence of
moving information view microscopically
that's right okay interesting Sabina
what is
gravity so I I have to be on another
panel later today where I'm supposed to
answer the question what's a
particle uh which is why I've actually
thought about this question I came to
the answer that I don't think this is a
question for science I would say what we
do in Sciences we describe observations
so I can tell you what we use to
describe the effect that we call gravity
we describe it with a curved
differential manifold uh of Dimension
four that has lorenzian signature and to
me that's a satisfactory answer that
that's that's what I would say it is
uh I'm just afraid that most people
wouldn't understand what it means so
does that mean uh we don't need to know
what it is as a physicist right we just
have to explain what we observe we
accept it as a given it is something we
work with to try to calculate or yeah so
from a pragmatic perspective we just
need mathema we are both saying
something like we have an operational
definition that we think works and we're
happy with it well it works more or less
yeah yes more or less yes okay three
different uh takes on gravity so gravity
is kind of special and I think with that
we have to let this debate fall to the
ground I really want to thank the
amazing speakers Kaa Eric and
Sabina the podcast talks debates courses
and articles visit the Institute of Art
and ideas click the link on screen now
to I
a.tv